This morning, the highly anticipated
release of the new
Harry Potter game, Hogwarts
Legacy is shrouded with some controversy.
Some fans are expected to boycott
to protest author J.K.
Rowling's comments
offensive to the transgender
community are.
Vanessa Yurkevich reports
in light of your unique situatio
Joining us is a fifth year.
We've devised something
extraordinary to ensure your suc
Harry Potter is back,
but not in the way
diehard fans may be used to do.
In the new Open World
video game Hogwarts
legacy players can experience
the world of Harry Potter,
but set in the 19th century
and with new characters.
The player isn't Harry,
Ron or her Minnie,
but their very own,
which are wizard, avatar,
It's pretty much like my dream
of being in Hogwarts.
It feels like a real life.
Harry Potter
Hogwarts Legacy Made by Avalanch
and Warner Brothers Discovery.
CNN's parent company
has been five years in the makin
After two rollout
delays,
the game is finally hitting the
The expectations are quite high,
not just from the consumers,
but also from the game makers th
Some estimates
suggest the game
cost $150 million to make.
But in a $200 billion
industry, bigger than film or mu
the payoff could be huge.
My expectation for this title
is that it's
going to easily sell 10 million
which puts it very much into the
very quickly.
The game already broke a record
for being the most
watched single player game
played by streamers who got it e
And it's the number one
presale this week on the gaming
platform Steam.
Warner Brothers
has 20 years of experience
putting out Harry Potter video g
But based on the movies,
how is Warner Brothers
been in terms of a game maker?
A little Rocky.
They definitely put out some big
and work with some big franchise
But their games have been hit an
This definitely feels is somethi
You know, Harry Potter is.
Hold that thought.
One of two calls during our inte
from someone looking for the gam
It's not a commercial risk
so much as it is a cultural one.
J.K.
Rowling, the creator of Harry Po
has made a series of offensive c
about the trans community
forcing pushback
from some of the movie's
actors and fans,
some who are boycotting the new
Warner Brothers Discovery
says Rowling is not involved in
but stands to make licensing roy
I thought it was going to impact
my view on the whole Harry Potte
But right now I am able
to separate the
situation with the ticket role
in the Harry Potter world.
But the controversy has turned
some fans off.
Do you still Harry Potter fan?
No, I think just
I think it's become weirdly divi
And I'm old now, so I don't care
Divisive, however,
because of the weird tension bet
the creator, the fans,
it perhaps as it
has room to
develop
something new to iterate
on the existing relationship
with its fanbase.
So perhaps,
you know,
making it into this
big production video game
allows the franchise
to kind of save itself
a little bit from the drag
that it's been experiencing cult
And we have CNN producer Carolin
playing the game live
right now on television.
The reviews have been really goo
for this game so far.
People love the visual
look they feel like it's very re
They love that
they can create their own charac
They're learning as they play th
But some are complaining
that it takes a little too long
to learn certain skills
to then fly the broom.
That's sort
of what Harry Potter is known fo
And as you noticed,
Carolyn is playing as a single p
We can't play with her
because this is not a multiplaye
And some videogame
experts are saying that that's
actually a revenue
lost opportunity
for the brand
because when you have multiple p
it allows you to purchase into t
of which you can play together.
You can also do in-game purchase
create new worlds
and levels by purchasing more.
So some experts say
that we will eventually get ther
But as of right now,
this is just you as your person
that's supposed to be me
but this is the Harry Potter
world of today.
And as of right now,
people are really excited
to see what it can do.
This is the Christmas
for Harry Potter fans and gamers
Tomorrow when it comes out.
Carol, what do you guys think?
Are you at.
I'm sorry, which house are you i
I have
I am in a bank vault and I'm stu
And I need to
beat these statues at some point
And this is what people are sayi
It's like you get stuck in here
for a little too long
and you can't move on to the nex
But there's still a lot
to do while you're here.
Okay.
Be
daughter, like two all the way b